les sables d'olonne à toute vapeur il
est désormais possible d'aller de paris
à la célèbre station balnéaire sans
descendre du tgv problème les lignes
vendéenne n'étant pas électrifier le tgv
rallye nantes au sable tracté par une
locomotive diesel ce qui est une
première en france philippe de maria et
philippe ridet l'alliance du moderne et
du traditionnel 7 motrices diesel vient
doucement s'accoupler a sauté j'ai tenu
son rôle
épaulé la rame à grande vitesse de
nantes jusqu aux sables d'olonne la
ligne n'est pas électrifiée et grâce à
cette manoeuvre les vacanciers parisiens
rejoignez les coudes vendéenne sans
aucun changement en garde les mineurs
encore sont les vacances dans ce sens
qu'en payant
je ne savais pas qu'il existait et donc
je pensais que automatiquement il y
avait un changement et j'avais regardé
ça fait très très long j'ai un bébé j'ai
beaucoup bagages et dont tout seul c'est
pas possible
ouais c'est beaucoup mieux
indirectes comme ça n'a pas trop
attendre quand tu paye un peu de musique
cigarettes
plus rapide plus pratique et sans
augmentation du prix du billet paris les
sables pourtant 18 millions de francs
ont été nécessaires pour modifier le
matériel tracter une rame de 500 tonnes
à 120 km heure ne s'improvise pas il
nous a fallu aménager huit rames tgv et
trois locomotives pour assurer ce
service nouveau service depuis le 28 mai
la station balnéaire des sables émis au
siècle dernier grâce à l'arrivée du
train
autant dire qu'ici on connaît
l'importance d'une bonne desserte
ferroviaire les collectivités locales
verse donc 15 millions de francs par an
pour faire venir le tg ce sillon
balnéaire doit vivre avec des
équipements nous les avons mais elle
doit être facile d'accès aux touristes
c'est indispensable
facile d'accès pour l'été mais facile
d'accès pour tous les ponts et les
week-end de pâques à la toussaint
et pour l'été seulement la ligne est
prolongée jusqu'à la plage un changement
est tout de même nécessaire en gare des
sables de meubles